I said at the start of the last lecture,
that after the episodes that I will be discussing,
then the cable Montesinos and a master Peter's puppet show,
three significant new developments take place in the Quixote.
I want to go over them again.
The first is that Don Quixote will sometimes not be the center of the action,
which will focus instead on on Saint Jo.
Uh,
the second is that both protagonists become objects of amusement for
aristocratic frivolous characters that I've read part one and want them to
behave according to it.
The 30th [inaudible] sanctuary will be surrounded by many more characters than
before.
The overarching theme of the Nobel continues to be the thing ganja.
And most of the episodes that staged by authors within the fiction,
which is highly theatrical.
And the backstage of the pranks,
the stage machinery,
I said,
where is revealed to the reader are either during the,
their performance or right after
the episode of the enchanted boat,
uh,
of which I gave you a,
an illustration of which appears in the handout that I gave you,
uh,
what's needed to get our protagonists across the river.
Um,
how are we going to show a map?
Oh,
Spain,
although we have already shown you a map about where this appears,
uh,
um,
we have to get them across the [inaudible].
I forgot my 23rd today,
but you can see the evidence right there.
Okay.
MMM.
In part one,
the territory that Doki hotel and San Jo covered was,
was not very specific in geographic terms.
Seville is mentioned as the destination of the prostitutes at the first in.
And,
uh,
also it is mentioned as the destination of undress when he pierce.
Uh,
the Sierra Morina is the setting for donkey holders pennants and the place where
Cardinia is hiding in shame and in madness,
at least relative vagueness is consensus consistent with the narrators refusal
to mention the village where along Saki handle lives and to which Don Quixote
returns.
Now,
however,
in part to geography becomes much more precise starting with Dorsal,
uh,
our protagonists first stop,
which is a real village in Castille and continuing with their original
destination said,
I also where Don Quixote wants to participate in just celebrated on St George's
Day,
April 23rd.
And we talked about that in one of my earlier,
uh,
glasses,
stream figures in the episode of the fully hammers,
but now don Quixote and sanctuary on their way to start,
I was have to get across the [inaudible],
one of the major rivers of Spain.
We could see another image of there you are of the,
uh,
of the Avatar.
Yeah.
I highlight this because of course,
Castille still is not only landlocked,
but there is very little water in Casteel and this is reflected in the,
uh,
in the novel where,
it only rains once in part.
Uh,
one,
uh,
there is a stream where the fooling hammers,
appear.
But on the whole there is very little water.
I'm going to turn the lights back on.
Okay.
So the second part adds geographic concrete next to it's rare realistic
portrayal of Spanish life.
This is not new with,
uh,
Cervantes.
This he derives from the picker risk in Los Angeles.
Total mess torments is a river is the river,
uh,
that goes through a Salamanca as a matter of fact.
And in the Mandale farace.
Uh,
the geography is quite a precise and,
uh,
both in Spain and in Italy where a Guzman travels also through,
through Italy.
Uh,
so Cervantes US derived this concreteness from,
uh,
from the picaresque.
Uh,
but the episode of the enchanted boat,
uh,
also serves to highlight comically of course,
the difference between Don Quixote's obsolete,
totally make notions of geography and the new Copernican conception of the
universe,
which is being expanded both US knowledge and as a field of knowledge as
Cervantes rights.
What I mean by that is the Copernican Universe is infinite.
The Ptolemaic Universe Universe is limited.
Now,
this a Galileo was making,
uh,
important discoveries in favor of Kapernick aneurysm in the early decades of a
17th century.
He was in Spain for a while
and developing,
developing instruments of observation like the telescope.
Okay.
But donkey Quixote still adheres to Ptolemaic ideas and calculations as he
demonstrates in his hilarious exchange to the sanctuary when he asks his squire
to check if he has any lies on his body.
Because it was come on,
Lord,
that upon crossing the equator,
all sorts of vermin would perish,
as if by magic sensual discovers that his fleas are lives,
are still very much alive.
And he is,
he underscores the plural once saying that the,
he has a few,
uh,
like chivalry.
Ptolemaic geography is a medieval retention,
struggling to survive in a world in which after the discovery and settlement of
the new world,
it was wholly on tenable except to the likes of Don Quixote or to Saint Joe who
doesn't care either way.
It doesn't make any difference to Saint Joe.
Of course.
Uh,
the crossing of the river is significant also because our characters are moving
beyond landlocked Castille toward coastal regions of Spain that are in touch
with other cultures and languages.
And in this second part,
uh,
we will,
we will reach such areas.
Barcelona work at alliance spoke.
Uh,
the episode is,
is,
is a rewriting since we're talking also always about,
uh,
these episodes of part two being rewritings of episodes of part one.
This,
I'd be,
so,
to me,
it's every writing of the windmills episode in part one,
uh,
because of the wheels of the in the river now
with similar results,
except that donkey healthy on Sancocho have again to make restitution for,
for damages,
uh,
and us all crossings.
This crossing is also a transition.
Now,
I have given you a handout,
uh,
with a scene of donkey helps us exchange.
We've censure on the issue of the distance they have traveled in a n and as this
exchange appears in various English translations so that we can be amused by,
uh,
the efforts that the translators would make,
to render the into English,
the ponds that are involved,
which are a little bit obscene in the Spanish.
If you have your handout.
If not,
I have copies.
If anybody need one.
Uh,
after essential wonders how much they have travel.
He said Mucho
[inaudible] [inaudible] DNA global.
The Laowei de la Tierra,
say Google Romeo [inaudible] Margaret Focus is savvy.
Lami.
Dot.
Ramos coming out Geogen de la Linea part of yours,
the whole Sun Joe.
Okay.
With some at a segment that I put the Stegal,
they look [inaudible] tilt persona Butoh it gaffer Golang at Uda.
They may own or mail or no se Como the,
I think I spent in the last class the,
the ugly word in Spanish to say to urinate matter equal and in English two pis
and of course in the word Ptolemy,
in Spanish Dolo Mineo that seems to be included.
The first person singular of the indicative of the word matter.
Yo Man,
this is what central hears until [inaudible] male's name and gum puto
computation.
Of course,
to him,
what he hears is Pluto,
which is the masculine of Pluto,
which is hard and it means homosexual.
So,
uh,
what,
Don Quixote has,
has told him,
lacks or authorities what he's saying when these authorities have to do,
uh,
with,
a person who is a homosexual and a on someone who business a lot.
And,
uh,
this is what,
central,
uh,
here's,
the,
uh,
the efforts by our translator by Grv.
It's not very good by the Lord called sanctuary.
Your worship has brought up very,
very pretty fellow.
That same tone me,
how do you call him with his amputation to vouch the truth of what you say?
It's trying to get computation and amputation to try to get the Pun.
It's not very funny.
It's not very good.
Uh,
uh,
smaller than the same 18th century tries to get four God cried Sankyo your
worship as broad a set of where witnesses to prove the truth of what you say.
Copulation and kiss gaffer with the addition of tooling me or some such name.
This is actually better because it catches the spirit of the obscenity of what
central is.
A is a is saying,
uh,
our
own Rutherford from Oxford University.
Good.
God said Santo,
that's a fine character.
You've dredged up as a witness with his sexy butts and he's Tom foolery.
And what's more a great pornography or whatever it was you sent me.
Is that Oh,
uh,
efforts.
The point is that of course they run.
This is making fun of the whole Ptolemaic System,
which by this time it's obsolete.
But Don Quixote of course,
uh,
is,
invoking it.
Asa whose authority to tell where it is or they're going,
as they write on the,
uh,
on the boat,
you're going to also,
you're going to amuse yourself,
so can try your hand at translating that point if you want.
Now,
when Don Quixote unsent you arrive at the house of the Duke and Duchess,
they enter a realm of games and frivolity that they,
that they have not known before.
These are irresponsible aristocrats that belonged to the leisure class lecture
class.
And in fact,
the house in which the action takes place.
It's not even their regular house.
It is,
uh,
a summer home for recreation.
Okay.
Don Quixote first meets the Dutcher's who is out falcon hunting all decked out
for the occasion and surrounded by an entourage.
This business of hunting with Falcons was very ceremonial.
People just went out and,
uh,
with servants and so forth.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the fact them sewer,
the hawks were trained to catch the prey and uh,
and so forth.
That wasn't much a real exercise involved.
I think that the hawks did all the work,
but this is part of the recreation of the Sa Aristocrats.
Um,
the Duke and Duchess are devoted to pleasure,
one of which is obviously reading for they know,
part one of the chaotic quite well.
They are idle readers like the ones that run this addressed at the beginning of
part one and I under line idle and this description don't Quixote on sent your
like toys to the Duke and Duchess are better.
Better.
They are like literary characters,
which in fact that's exactly what they are.
Uh,
okay.
Everything in their home.
I mean you did don't kill the essential sort of fallen on their hands of these
people who are great readers apart one and wow know we have the real,
you hope,
the real quote Unquote Oak Hill,
the Monsanto at our own home.
And so they try to make uh,
uh,
the best of it.
Everything in,
in the Duke and Duchess is home.
It's like fiction.
Except that fiction fiction can be harsh and cruel.
What they're fiction proves the truth.
The truth of their fiction is that reality too is like fiction.
Uh,
under both reality and fiction can hurt actually what appears here is a reality.
he's always reality plus the props to create the fiction.
It's not reality by itself,
but reality improved by the,
or changed by the,
by the props.
This is the harshness of dissing Ganja.
Not only that,
uh,
being diluted can be hurtful.
Uh,
and to be on the alluded also can be hurtful,
but that the,
the physical process may indeed involve injury.
Peter,
he,
Russell,
the,
uh,
distinguished British history says quote,
the Duke and Duchess are remarkably on feeling aristocratic pranksters,
some of their jokes involving co involved causing physical harm to their two
guests.
They will see that,
okay,
Quixote scratch my cats.
Not The fall from the club.
Millennial.
The horse is very dangerous and,
and,
and so forth.
Okay.
You got Russell,
social satire directed at various levels of society is more prominent in this
chapter's than anywhere else in the book.
Or this is true social satire.
It's very,
very important in this chapter of the book.
In addition,
and this is a detail that I hope you pick up when you get to this part,
if you haven't gotten there yet yet,
the Duke and Duchess is expensive.
Pleasures are underwritten by the peasant who song those not want to marry.
Do I not Rodriguez,
his daughter,
which is the reason why no pressure is put on him by his master.
Remember,
this is conflict.
Another one of these conflicts on young people.
Uh,
this young man has a promise to married
daughter because he has impregnated her and so forth and she complains of no
pressure is brought upon this young man because his father,
who's a poor peasant within,
uh,
the Rome control by the Duke and Duchess Lens.
Then money lend some money at very opportune moments.
That is when the,
you can Dutcher's are in dire economic straits.
This is a very significant detail.
These are not only idle opera classes,
but opera classes in Hawk that they're high living with loans.
Okay?
Since you are readers of Elliot's Imperial's Spain,
you will no doubt see that.
It is easy to draw an analogy,
an analogy between the behavior of this aristocrats and the policies of the
Spanish crown,
which lives off the ship bins of precious metals from the new world and loans
from the fingers.
The German bankers who finance the expensive,
uh,
blushers of the Habsburgs are there court,
the building of the Palace of [inaudible] that you may still see him in Madrid.
Uh,
but Alaska is,
paints is Habsburgs,
uh,
humpty and engaging in this kind of,
this kinds of pleasures to all of that.
Uh,
all of that was,
uh,
or most of it was underwritten by loans from German bankers.
So this is all part of the political side of the 1615 Quixote,
which I mentioned before is the first political novel.
It's social satire,
which may involve political dimension.
In this context,
Saint Joseph's social aspirations,
uh,
do not appear that outlandish,
in the sense that Sorentos is showing that the social order and it's
hierarchies,
uh,
is crumbling when the upper classes are so corrupt.
And artists as is evident in that a peasant immune suppressant is supporting
this aristocrats in their activities.
Okay.
So,
oh,
this is a kind of a topsy turvy world,
the social world,
which bespeaks of,
uh,
erosion of a crumbling of his social order.
Uh,
and,
uh,
what's it run,
this is dramatizing here,
is that a new order is in [inaudible],
uh,
in which class mobility may very well be possible class mobility up or down.
Uh,
we see a characters.
I'd be stored in this household of the Duke and Duchess who has enormous power
over his,
his,
his masters.
And we see San Jo of course,
uh,
elevated even if it is fictional,
to governor of his island.
Finally.
So this whole,
uh,
the,
the second part of Hilton reveals,
Eh,
as I say,
a social order that is not as stable as it used to be.
Um,
that is a sort of a shaking
and,
uh,
he's giving us very precise surrenders.
He was very precise,
uh,
financial,
details about,
uh,
about this through this satire,
the kind of of of financial detail that you own,
you expect to find only in 19th century novel as Balzac's Nola in,
in which of course the financial,
uh,
dealings of the characters play a very important role.
But here already instead of [inaudible],
we have this details such as the fact that the Duke gets loans from his peasant.
Yeah,
fix your nurse performed at the Duke's house is mirth full and playful,
but also cruel and caring as I said,
fix your on is also a femoral,
a femoral,
an insubstantial,
like the props that hold it up with the Duke and Duchess Don Quixote on Santo
temporarily realize their dreams.
Don Quixote is treated like a great night and sanctuary Fay finally made
governor over done when the hotel enters into the Duke's a palatial summer home.
They have prompted already their help so that they can treat Doki hotels had
great presence and have all kinds of things ready for his comfort.
But these fabrications quickly disappear.
It is again the same [inaudible].
The truth or fiction is that it illuminates the fictional quality of real life
will be a femoral quality of real life if you want.
An American historian is Ruth Ellis Afar put her name
in spite of the name.
She was married to someone or Arabic origin.
She died very young.
Tragically
Joseph said,
piss a scholar.
She rode,
she writes quote,
all of part two is based on the mistaken assumption on the part of the would be
old controlling character offers that day can deal with a fictional character
and maintain at the same time and distance,
which allows them never to slip into that fictional world with which they plan
to entertain themselves.
Like Samsung continuous l suffer.
They are trapped from two directions.
They are control to some extent from within their play by the very characters,
from the intent to manipulate and from without,
by an author of whom they are on a wire,
by who's will and whose hand.
All they do is contrived on quote us.
We have seen already in the case of sandstone care,
rascal is controlling author that he falls into his own trap.
He loses to Don Quixote in this,
uh,
counter that they have.
And we will see a once and again that the steward who was a very clever fellow,
uh,
and create all of these elaborate pranks,
the sub succeed with them.
Okay.
Eventually they come tumbling down.
Um,
so some [inaudible] is the principal internal author,
as I said,
and as we've seen from the very beginning,
uh,
Ben to recreate recreating,
recreating the fiction of part one.
But now the Duke's house,
the Duke Steward,
we compete with Samsung,
uh,
quite favorably.
He is the creator of elaborate packs like the island.
We don't sanction would be governor like the pageant in the forest about which I
will speak very soon,
none of which turn out quite as he planned them and within which he gets caught.
Uh,
these steward,
by the way,
if you think about,
uh,
the pageant in the forest,
was,
uh,
not only,
clever in creating this banks,
but it was also a part,
he must've written the lines that Merlin delivers in this pageant.
So
the significance of all this,
uh,
apart from its baroque character is it's advantage is speculating as usual about
his own position.
Visa vie own fiction is fiction.
That seems to be always getting away from him,
from him.
And this is what the presence of this internal authors who are beset by these
problems,
uh,
of distance and control,
reveals,
which is the same kind of situation in which a master Peter find himself,
finds himself with his,
a puppet theater with got a straw fic results.
So then one of the early,
uh,
events that occur at the Duke and Dukes and Duchesses House is,
I'm sure you noticed,
uh,
is the debate donkey hold the house with the ecclesiastic.
Uh,
this is a criticism of the church not of religion and may also be a commentary
on Spanish politics and the role that the clergy is allowed to play in them.
So we have,
again,
another is I know the instance here of these social
and political criticism that appears in the know
don't be hot.
The intimates that the [inaudible] is a Leech leaving,
living at the expense of the Duke and Duchess,
who in turn live off of the rich peasant who pays,
who gives them loans,
uh,
don't get help.
They also tells him that he speaks without our authority because he lacks
experience and accuses him of acting aggressively because he is protected by his
investiture,
meaning that donkey health,
they cannot challenge him to a fight because he is a,
an ecclesiastical,
therefore,
he takes advantage of that protection to be able to act with this,
uh,
haughtiness.
But notice
that there is some truth to what the ecclesiastic says to the Duke and Duchess
about how they're dealing with donkey haughty,
encouraging him to go on with this insanity about being a knight errand.
There are no uniformly negative characters in,
and this even this very unpleasant priest is right in some of the things that he
says.
He ruins the whole dinner.
He's very unpleasant,
but he has some of the things he says are quite true.
Perspective is same as we have been seeing it in throughout the semester.
It means that no one is in possession of the entire truth.
That is truth made up of the various points of view of the characters.
Um,
under the truth.
Baby spoken by the most unlikely people,
even people who are not,
uh,
very pleasant.
This is a constant insert Landis,
uh,
notice that the debate with the [inaudible] in this case,
we could call it a pre prandial dinner.
So I'd be a pretty Pinedale speeches,
the speech before dinner,
which was ruined anyway by this and that,
uh,
it is a,
again,
another rewriting of the arms and letters speech because don't Quixote,
we seems to be able to get to that topic as it did at the house of Diego.
Them Eudanda when he debated about the virtuals of poetry and of uh,
uh,
the military.
Now we move on now to let be souls that are quite independent,
uh,
and,
that seemed to build not on part one bottom previous episodes of parts.
Who,
uh,
is this fiction issuing from fiction.
It's like a telescope that you're pulling out from within itself.
What is happening in these episodes that fallen?
Now,
think of it as that a telescope and as you pull it out,
you're pulling things from within it.
And that is the way that these episodes are.
I'm going to discuss now appear in,
uh,
in,
in part two.
You said very important episodes,
not quite on the level of the cave of Montesinos,
but very important.
I'm very memorable episodes and that sort of make it coherent unit,
although,
uh,
there will be a return,
to the Duke and Duchess,
his house when Don Quixote is on his way back home.
Um,
so we begin by the episode of the humped.
Uh,
and,
and we have here again this,
uh,
effect of the receding sequences,
the episode of the hunt,
uh,
and the,
elaborate pageant in the forest are games within games place within a place.
Um,
what is the hunt?
The hunt is a mock war,
uh,
aristocrats no longer participating wars as we have been a c all along.
So they now engage in mock wars.
Specifically in hunting.
We saw that both the chaotic and Don Diego de Miranda are hunters.
Hunting of,
of the boar involves strategies that are akin to those of a battle demanding,
uh,
horsemanship as well as the playing of drums and various horns and trumpets.
Much of the ceremonial aspects of war are reproduced in hunting.
War has become a sport and sports modern sports to our mock wars,
think for a moment of American football,
which is,
uh,
the metaphor of war is very crass in American football.
I invade your territory,
whereas the other team defense his territory.
And so there is a dividing line,
which is like the frontier between these two countries at war.
And all of the terminology is derived from,
uh,
from the military.
All of this,
what I called back and forth,
sports hockey,
soccer,
football,
lacrosse are back and forth because you stand there and they go back and forth,
back and forth,
uh,
are across metaphor.
Uh,
for war,
uh,
if you,
if a Martian got off his spaceship and you took him to a football game,
the Martian would be able to understand very soon what is going on.
Not so with baseball,
by the way,
in baseball,
the war metaphor is very elaborate.
You run around the bases in a circle to come back home like Ulysses and all of
that,
but that,
yes,
yes.
Uh,
this is not just a defensive baseball because as you know,
I've written quite a bit on,
on baseball and played the game a lot,
but it is,
it is simply the truth.
Uh,
and all these other sports that I've mentioned and hunting,
of course our CRAs metaphors for war in baseball.
The metaphor,
it's more baroque actually.
He's,
it's not convoluted,
but the outcome of course,
a of sports contests.
I like a war.
I think it's tomorrow.
Uh,
the,
the New York Yankees who I've just won the world series last night,
they're going to be paraded down,
uh,
the,
the streets of New York with ticker tapes.
And it's as if they hadn't been returning heroes like those in Rome who came
back and built arches and so forth.
So much for sports.
But I want to underline the fact that hunting has become a sport and this is
what the,
uh,
these aristocrats I engaged in.
Uh,
Sandra of course runs up the tree scared by the,
by this board,
which a,
these are dangerous animals with along with tusks like this and all of that.
Now,
uh,
I seen Camacho's wedding notice the transition,
the episode begins,
the episode of the whole pageant in the forest begins with a kill the animal.
I,
if a scape goat where needed to start the action and also escape goat were
needed for the feast.
Feast ceremonies and parties,
uh,
demand,
seem to demand escape goat of some sort.
It doesn't have to be a gold.
Of course,
it can be a Turkey in Thanksgiving and uh,
and so forth.
Or it could be a pig in many celebrations,
but it seems to be an atavistic need of the human race to have this scape.
Goats,
uh,
there had been a recent instances in Spain.
I have seen,
I have seen it disgusts in the newspapers where new traditions of this kind have
emerged and the towns have the practice that when they have their,
their big feast,
they take a goat up on the church steeple and throw him off and kill him that
way.
Gross.
Uh,
but,
uh,
when I'm on the lining is at the beginning,
the killing of this bore here has sort of an atavistic ritualistic air to it.
So
now this pageant in the forest is one of the most baroque episodes in the whole
of the jihadi.
The episode gather God episode gathers elements of the Cave and want to see
[inaudible] and the [inaudible] of the parliament of death.
It is a kind of synthesis of both.
Uh,
this is what I meant by episodes that are derived from episodes like a
telescope.
Can you open like that?
But it is also a version or more
accurately a pair version or,
uh,
second moment in Dante [inaudible].
And I gave you a handout in the previous class with some,
uh,
with a fragment of [inaudible] 29,
because these episodes here,
as I will describe in some detail,
are a tank off the parody of these,
uh,
episodes in the divine comedy.
No less.
I told you that now.
I said,
Ron,
this is sources are not just the romances of chivalry,
but,
uh,
all avid Virgil,
homer and done now in Dante,
this in Dante's Commedia,
this is a moment of an ignore is of discovery of self discovery for the pilgrim.
The pilgrim poet is left if I Virgil,
who has guided him up to this point and who will not be able to enter paradise
because he's a pagan.
So he is left,
the pilgrim is left on his own to meet Beatrice,
very dwells in limbo at the entrance of inferno where he is lodged with other
worthies of the pagan world.
Neither,
uh,
punished nor rewarded.
This is a marvelous invention of dentists limbo or he puts all of these great
figures of antiquity who could not,
she didn't say came before Christ,
could not have been Christian,
therefore they cannot enter paradise.
And they were put here in limbo where they are together in this palace.
Uh,
neither happy nor sad,
the kind of a smile.
Let me steer your smile on their face,
discussing their works with each other.
It's a kind of a perpetual seminar.
It's not bad.
Um,
now,
so that's where Virgil dwells and he left to accompany the pilgrim all the way
up but not quite into a paradise.
Of course,
the whole object of the journey was to find Beatrice.
The pilgrim moves on to the end of,
uh,
purgatorial to do,
we met by Beatrice.
I will get to the solemn profession,
that profession,
the solemn procession that meets him.
I don't wish the one in this.
He said,
Ron,
this is based,
but first let me tell you that the meeting with Beatrice is to me one of the
funniest moments in the whole of the western literary tradition
after the pilgrim poet has gone through all of hell and most of purgatory in
order to meet her.
The first thing the Beatrice does when they do meet is to reproach him for
having been with other women after his death.
I find this delicious and very,
very funny and a great lesson.
No good deed shall go on punished,
but what ensues in Dante is an elaborate procession as us,
Beatrice appear that it's front there.
March seven luminaries,
the seven gifts of the Holy Ghost followed by the 20 elders of the apocalypse.
Canticles announce the impending arrival of Beatrice for mystic animals up here,
the four gospels and a cart pulled by a Griffin,
the four cardinal virtues follow and then the three theological virtues we Saint
Peter and Saint Paul for Doctors of the Church and Saint John.
The procession stops before the pilgrim port.
That triumphant Beatrice Symbol of theology makes her appearance.
This is the background of the pageant to distort,
has organized with the help of other servants of the Duke and Duchess,
including the beautiful page playing the role of dual scenario
one must pause to ponder at least Ipos to ponder the distance between the
universe created by Dante in the divine comedy and that created by Cervantes
indeck haughty.
The pageant in the forest is quite a bold parody verging on the irreverent,
on the part of the Atlantis.
What makes the difference between Dante's and Cervantes?
This worlds,
this is what we must ask ourselves at this point.
The progressive,
in my view,
is the progressive crumbling of the certainties of the Medieval world,
their cosmology grounded on the Ptolemaic system that has been shattered by the
discovery of the new world and the Copernican Revolution,
the Protestant reformation and the schism in the Christian Church.
The minute orders,
symbolic universe of Christian doctrine apparent immediately well cathedrals and
in the divine comedy is no longer available.
The fusion of neoplatonic love and its courtly derivatives,
which could,
which could coalesce in the figure of Beatrice,
uniting worldly love with divine love and faith has been torn asunder.
So saw that what Don Quixote fines in this brilliant scene is not a Beatrice but
it transvestite Dulcinea,
a transvestite billionaire.
No less.
Who reveals to him perhaps the depths of his madness and the true nature of his
desire.
Yeah.
Have you had an arrow who might have caught at many times in the course of the
semester,
says the following?
It is a remarkable twist of Cervantes is irony that the incarnated Dulcinea is a
lie of the dukes built on a previous line of sanctuary to top it all till Chanel
as really a man,
that page of the dukes that the steward has selected to play this role because
of his Bilty such as the ontological status of the earthy Dulcinea elaborates of
lights built upon lies,
a contradict of contradictory appearances on quote.
Okay,
think about this.
Think about the difference between Beatrice and this dude.
See now,
I mean it's a huge difference.
I mean between the sublime image of Beatrice who incarnates,
uh,
theology in the divine comedy.
Uh,
and this,
uh,
hilarious figure of a deal of the Dukes,
but page who's very beautiful playing the role of a,
of duty.
Now this is the evolution of the,
the evolution of the,
of,
of the ideal woman from Dante to serve Lantis,
which goes through Laura in patriarchy.
We saw,
well fray the English,
the Lasso and all of these,
uh,
winds up in this,
in this brilliant figure of the transvestite Lucy now that we have here in this
pageant on the forest.
I mean,
this is,
this is where it's a rented reaches,
a level of a penetration into the evolution of,
of the Western mind that it's really,
uh,
that are really uncanny and where we have not really gone much,
beyond.
Okay.
Now the pageant in the forest is bristling with Baroque elements.
It is the most baroque scene in the entire novel.
First,
it takes place in a Carol squirrel atmosphere and I've explained what Carroll
School Royce
as we shall see,
a darkness that is half illuminated by torches.
It is a fabrication and construction and assemblage of disparate elements,
theatrical,
self conscious,
humorous.
It is play I need is a play the card set up here carrying the costume players
are like those use to represent out of Sacramento Talis.
Remember those uh,
allegorical outdoors.
I have mentioned several times like the one in the wire on of the parliament of
death episode
as in much of the second part.
These are complicated borderless pranks based on literary allusions like the
Cave of Montesinos episode,
which Jew from the classical tradition and the romances of chivalry.
Remember uh,
the descent to hades in homer and Virgil and one in the romances of chivalry.
Here in this pageant in the forest,
we have us in the cave literary figures like Merlin,
Marilyn and the devil's representing themselves.
That is you think that a literary figure represents presumably a real person,
but here is a literary figures who are representing literary figures.
He said there are several layers of functionality here.
It is literally a don task world with clear illusions.
As I've mentioned to purgatorial 28 30 28 29 and 30 a baroque art is,
we call it in Spanish [inaudible].
It ain't said generating reactions on the audience because of its outrageous
dementia or it's exaggerated qualities.
That's the essence of the Baroque.
The reader is treated to the effects of this art and shown its effect on the
spectators and participants like Sancha who faiths.
Okay.
And and also its effect even on those who are responsible for the whole terrain,
they are caught within their own fiction,
the Duke and Duchess and are scared.
Okay.
The most jarring effect in this episode is cost by sound.
And if we turn to pages six 95 six 96 I'm going to read a passage
that begins and the last paragraph with these and the like entertaining
discourses,
they left the tent and went into the woods to visit the toils and next.
This was the in the world of the hunt.
The day was sutent.
Soon spent a night,
came on,
not so clear,
nor socom as the season of the year,
which was the midst of summer required,
but a kind of Claire Obscure Chiaroscuro.
This is what,
uh,
Jarvis just trying to get out,
which contributed very much to help forward the dukes and duchesses design.
Now night coming on soon after the toilet on a sudden the would seem them fire
from all the four quarters.
I'm presently,
we're heard on all sides an infinite number of corners and other instruments of
war as if a great body of horse was passing through the wood,
the blaze of the fire on the sound of the war,
like instruments almost blinded and stunned the eyes and ears of the bystanders
and even have all that were in the world.
Presently we're heard infinity lily,
Lily's,
which is a sound that the more is made,
uh,
when they are just going to battle Trump is and clarion sounding drums,
beat five splayed and almost all at ones so fast and without intermission that
he must have had no sense who had not lost it.
Uh,
the confused didn't have so many instruments on quote the Song Confulco confused
sound causes past month or his astonishment.
So spanx,
oh,
suspense at [inaudible],
admiration and spanked,
frightened according words from the,
from the original.
The key here is to shrill this harmony.
The sounds are her uncle,
horse and a spam.
Social fragmenting their voices or on a horrible,
the devil is sounding at this Sappho Rado Queer know Rachel's harm.
These are,
there are visual effects to the devils are ugly.
Those fails the millennials and Marilyn has the figure of death is terrifying.
This whole scene he's cast in this clash of sounds and sights artificially
created for effect even in the translation that of Yoast red,
uh,
you can hear that Savantas has created this effect also stylistically with harsh
sounding words and own Amato payers.
There is words that sound like what they represent.
Now,
in addition to all of this,
uh,
Baroque,
atmosphere,
uh,
douchey now is a transvestite.
I get back to that duty.
Nat is a man.
These guys,
as a beautiful woman,
more precisely,
a beautiful young man.
This guys,
as a beautiful young woman,
it is underlying that the page is beautiful.
This is the most outrageous of the transformations that Dulcinea on their goes,
even worse than her appearing as a peasant wench smelling of garlic.
It makes her femininity is something artificial that can be fortunate with the
proper disguise.
The transvestite is a common baroque figure in Spanish literature because in the
Baroque,
even gender can be constructed,
fabricated from the idea of beauty drawn from the neoplatonic and the court.
We love tradition from which Gnocchi Hoda invents dual scenario two,
the grotesque Peston of Sanchez lie to this baroque construction that is an
increase in the level of fabrication or what deficient artificiality.
I guess we do invent the objects of our desire.
This is what the novel keeps telling us.
You gotta be careful.
You don't invent the object of your desire.
And it turns out to be a transvestite.
Uh,
um,
I have seen some that can really fool anybody.
Uh,
I wrote a book on a Cuban writer called [inaudible] who's chief figure is the
transfer stock.
He lived in Paris and I,
uh,
visited with him a few places that are not in the tourist guides
and where you would find a transfer starts that God really fool anybody.
The grotesqueness mentored here and made even funnier by the feature that
exposes do sedans,
true gender,
which is her voice.
Okay,
Jer,
Jeremy's flubs.
The translation are Jarvis.
In the original it says,
don't see now.
[inaudible] voice was not very either mother from Dama lady at the mother.
The voice was not very lady like,
okay.
Jarvis rendition as amiable.
Ah,
he ruins the whole effect.
No dual Chanel's voice voices masculine.
She'd also a warrior.
So once you get delivered his speech,
the contrast is that she's beautiful because the page is beautiful and dressed
like a beautiful woman.
But suddenly what emerges from her is a,
is a hoarse voice over a male.
She has too much testosterone.
And this contrast,
this clash is what is important here and done.
Lamentably uh,
Jarvis flubbed it.
Uh,
this whole episode makes me think of a movie that is perhaps too old for you to
have seen it,
but it's such a classic that you may have seen it,
some like it hot with Marilyn Monroe.
Uh,
it's just a wonderful movie on the very last line.
It's a classic because when the old man is just continuous,
uh,
to,
to insist that he,
that lemon is,
is,
uh,
is the,
is lemon dig the Guy John Lennon or what is the Clint playing the,
the transvestite.
Uh,
he finally defense is,
but I'm not even a woman.
And then of course,
nobody's perfect.
Uh,
answers,
answers her eager lover.
And I guess these two see now is not perfect.
I mean,
first of all,
she said,
man,
she made me beautiful.
And in addition to that,
she hauls of Horace.
That is just not a very feminine.
This whole elaborate prank is concocted.
To listen champ do scenario to bring her out of the stadium when sand in which
sank,
just like put her,
hence the need within this grotesque fiction for central to punish himself by
giving himself 3000 lashes on his buttocks.
The prank has a logic of its own,
which operates at the level of the lies which are fictions in their own right at
that level,
centuries the culprit.
So he must pay the price.
Now I bought white lashes on his butt and neuro his back,
which is traditionally prisoners are uh,
uh,
punished by having a number of lashes.
I've ministered to their bare backs,
but here is through his bare bottom.
There's of course adds to the humor of the whole terrain because Sandra of
course wants to protect his bought literally a,
he's a,
he's not going to have any such thing happened to him,
but of course it is an allusion to Sanchez being so dependent on his digestive
system,
must it where he has already defecated twice in the normal.
Remember in part one in the falling hammers.
And then when he takes that,
uh,
concoction,
the donkey hold it gives me money,
has a terrible bout of diarrhea.
So,
uh,
defecation and the rear end are very much a part of central.
He has,
uh,
his,
his rear frank just rear represents,
he's freshly character.
It is,
it is his signature or as much as his belly is the last name a Pantser,
if you nail it on the Duke and Duchess Walking Castle.
Duetto
okay.
Spanish.
His Spanish from the forties
saves the Duke at the Duke's house.
Doki hold the field for the first time,
like a real night errand,
but that this is not enough.
And this is the quote from Castle Doro translated by me man's inner reality.
Six to be confirmed in society,
which when it gratifies the amount of action,
grandson,
a personality,
but any social confirmation of what is a spiritual is always a parody.
Don't Quixote.
A spiritual man sees his own image as a knight errand.
Would you have here to four always contemplated in the purity of action.
It is an image of his external self.
The owner's social status,
the fame that society can grant the man of the spirit are nothing but a
burlesque image of him.
A distortion of his inner life on quote cause a lot of positives at any
manifestation of one's inner life in the world outside has necessarily a to B
burlesque that he cannot match its essence in the purity of thought.
And
perhaps funky heartache is making this discovery as he is subject to pranks like
those he suffered at the hands of the Duke and the Duchess and their menus.
Now I want to end with a few words about the pretended aunt because you have
written a paper due return in today,
uh,
in which,
following,
uh,
Auerbach and Spitzer on the notion of the servant Yan using that knowledge,
you are applying it to your reading of the pretended aunt and dried to decide if
it was written or not by Cervantes.
This is a story that appeared in a bundle of manuscripts that included some of
the fantasy stories [inaudible] and quarterly,
but that are not,
uh,
but it was not signed.
And of course the debate has raised over the centuries,
uh,
as to whether it was,
written by Cervantes or not in favoring of considering the story.
Do we serve Lantus?
I would say that [inaudible] is an independent young woman who shaves her future
by dint of her will and courage.
She rebels and whites up,
winds up married to a well to do young man.
She erased her,
pass us a whore and becomes respectable and married in this year's like others.
Advantis characters like Marcella,
Dorothea and [inaudible] and also in favor of the story ends with an equal
marriage similar to those in the Quixote.
That successful one at that against is being by Cervantes,
Eh,
is the strong,
uh,
strong influence of cellists.
Dena above all in the,
in the salacious episodes,
um,
details about repairing virgins.
There's nothing quite as dirty in any texts by Cervantes,
including the receipt for marriage and the dog's colloquy stories that you will
be reading towards the end of the semester.
It could be a way out.
Could be,
is that it could be by a,
an early Cervantes story.
Before he was Atlantis.
It could be a Savantas,
uh,
imitator who wrote it,
and so forth.
But how many of you here thought that it was written by Cervantes?
Raise your hands.
One,
two,
three,
four.
How many thought not,
yeah,
how many didn't dig us that aside,
did you,
you didn't take any sides.
Okay.
Not Fair.